in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
with me in the studio today is aging
researcher dr. Christophe engli welcome
to in good shape hello we just saw the
stories about the warms but what do
warmth tell us about humans I think they
can tell us a lot so experience over the
last years on research in worms has
shown that there was some principal
discovered and probably also yet to be
discovered which are also applicable and
for human aging okay but you yourself
don't just do warms you do research on
some special kind of fish so the worms
are great but the fish we think is at
least as great it has the advantage of
being in terms of evolution in terms of
conservation of certain pathways and
genes being more closer to the human
situation it's fish are vertebrates like
humans so we think that whatever we
discover in the fish might be even more
relevant for human aging than what we
discover in in worms cause that closer
to humans and the worms because they're
closer and the kind of the genes are
more similar between a fish and a human
rather than between a warm and a human
yeah the best thing would be doing
research on humans so but you don't do
it because humans live too long well it
would be good to do research on humans
in a way but of course yes it's a
species which is very long-lived a PhD
student has three to four years where he
or she has to finish her experiment
humans live up 220 obviously you cannot
do meaningful experiments with those in
the lifetime of a scientist when I speak
to my patients in my office and I say I
want to grow old I want to be old they
say they don't some of them they don't
because they're afraid of being old so
I'm taking a look into Western society
it is that being old has some kind of
stigma on this what do you think about
this yes I think it's very unfortunate
you're right that in Western societies
it's that it has a very negative
connotation I think it's not good in
Asian societies that is different where
people who are always treated with
respect more respect than here this
probably comes from what you said from
the fact that there is kind of a a
inevitable relationship between coming
old and
becoming sick however there are examples
there are many examples of people who
become became very old and without being
sick and that's one of the goals that
actually we have to make humans become
old but not necessarily become sick so
this is one of the goals you have as an
aged researcher I think this is one of
the main goals that page research
actually has one is of course to
decipher to analyze the mechanisms which
contribute to aging because we're still
not really understanding that we have no
comprehensive view and what aging is
actually how it is brought about so that
is one goal and the other goal is to
contribute to healthy human aging to
what we say usually to extend the health
span not necessarily lifespan but health
span yeah right so what are the factors
associated with the health span or the
the life span my grandma lived until the
age of 87 does it mean that that I can
live that long too or can I even grow
older I think the fact that you have
parents grandparents in your family who
actually became very old is already puts
you in a good position to become old
yourself because we know that of course
much of how long how we age and I hope
we can become is encoded in our genes
this does not ignore the fact that of
course environment behavior plays also a
big role nevertheless genes probably set
the frame of maximum lifespan and
whether you can actually get to this age
which is genetically predicted this
depends on your personal behavior your
diet your activities so I can do a lot
of things wrong and shorten my lifespan
but can I do everything right and
prolong it even if my genes code that I
would rather be 90 and not 100 I think
this is gonna be very difficult so if
you carry in you predisposition for
certain diseases this is something you
will not very hardly be able to overcome
by behavior there are diseases where you
can do a lot to prevent or postpone them
however others which break out
independent of what you do we mentioned
the TMS and what is the role of them and
why do they play any role
aging well the telomeres are the end of
our chromosomes these are kind of the
packages of our genetic material we know
that telomeres erode they are shortened
when we age in fact I have shorter
telomeres than my PhD students this is
something by the way we have really
tested and verified
so here's normal that's normal and it's
also almost inevitable because there is
no good way to prevent that
except you actually activate a
particular enzyme called telomerase
however that comes at a price because
our tumor cells have telomerase activity
they manage to actually maintain or even
elongate telomeres but that's very often
than youths to cancer so in a way they
can even reverse it reverse it so even
can elongate telomeres this is
somebody's enzyme which is required
needed for cancer but is it like that
that you got in a certain length of the
telomeres and they got shortened over
life and if they're gone you die well
there's there is a certain correlation
between shortening of telomeres and
onset of diseases so hard cardiovascular
diseases and so on and so forth so yes
there is some link between shortening of
telomeres and diseases it's not totally
clear whether really person dies because
one of the chromosomes was actually too
short M sports is said to help the
telomeres to stay longer so is this true
that Sports has an anti-aging effect I'm
not sure that there's really good
evidence my view and that would be that
somebody who does sport probably also in
other aspects of his or her life lives a
more conscious a more healthy a more
balanced life and I think that might
actually help also or might counteract
telomere shortening I'm not sure that
there is good evidence of sport and then
how much sport actually leads to a
negation of telomeres it's more the
whole package it's I not believe it is
the time you you spend running we got a
view question from Canada Sean George
wants to know how long will my life
expectancy increase on average if I swim
three to four times a week as a
scientist he'll say you should do that
you will benefit from that
I think this person will not only live a
longer life he will probably also live a
more happy and more balanced life and I
think this is what is important we
scientists cannot say by two kilometers
three kilometers per week you can extend
two years to your life I think this is
something which we cannot quantify it
and then what about dietary supplements
you can go into a pharmacy and buy some
vitamins and they say you will look
younger and you be younger if eat them
I'm very skeptical about this there are
certain types always you know some
vitamin is very popular in the 80s 90s
and then nobody talks about is that then
comes anti-cholesterol and then nobody
talks about it later
so I've not really a come across a good
dietary supplement I would say save the
money and spend it more wisely and what
about caloric restriction so not eating
that much that's what a hermanas from
the s wants to know yes there is good
evidence in many species in the mouse
and in the warm we've talked about that
if you feed those animals with less
calories that that extends life the
problem is that still we don't know how
that really works in detail we are not
totally sure that this is applicable to
humans and also there are studies which
people do not talk about so often the
dietary restriction in some ways can
also shorten the lifespan so the overall
message would be yes calorie restriction
seems to reduce or sorry to extend
lifespan to reduce also it associated
diseases however really don't understand
how it works exactly
and whether it's applicable to humans
okay thank you for saying uh for being
with us in the studio and one thing you
can say is don't get obese because
obesity shortens the life certainly
thanks so much for being with us in in
good shape thank you
you
you